you wrote a piece
in mit tech review saying that ai can't
be an artist
creativity is and always will be a human
endeavor
you mentioned burt and criticism of
symbolic ai
can you explain your view
of criticizing the possible the capacity
for artistry and creativity in uh our
robot friends uh yeah i can try
so
to make the argument
you have to have in mind
what counts as
art what counts as a creative artistic
act
i take it that
just doing something new
isn't sufficient
i mean we say that good art is original
but not everything that's never been
done before is good art
so there has to be more than just doing
something
new
it has to be
somehow doing something new in a way
that speaks to
the audience or speaks to
some portion of the audience at least it
has to be doing something new
in such a way
that some people who see or interact
with it
can see themselves anew
in it
so i think that art is inherently a
creative act it i'm sorry
a kind of
communicative act
that it it involves a relation with
other
people
so
think about the conditions for that
working
someone i talk in that article
i can't remember something about new
music i think i don't talk about
stravinsky but let's say stravinsky
um
stravinsky
you know performs the rite of spring and
there's
riots
it is
new
and people hate it
people can't sounds like a cacophony it
sounds awful it's it's written according
to principles that are not like the
principles of music composition that
people are familiar with
so in some ways it's a failed
communicative act
but as as nietzsche says about his own
stuff i mean
we now can recognize that it wasn't it
wasn't a failed communicative act it
just it just hadn't reached its time yet
and and now
that way of composing music is like you
know it's in disney movies you know it's
so part of our musical palette that we
don't we don't have that response it
changed us it changed the way we
understand what counts as good music
so that's a deep communicative act it
didn't
perform its communication in that
opening moment
but it did ultimately
establish a new understanding for all of
us of what counts as good art and that's
the kind of
deep communication that i think good art
can can do it can change our
understanding
of ourselves
and of what a good manifestation of
something of ourselves in a certain
domain is
and use the term
socially embedded that art is
fundamentally socially embedded yeah and
i really like that term because um
i see like my love for artificial
intelligence and the kind of system that
we can bring to the world that could
uh make for an
interesting and more lively world and
one that enriches human beings is one
where the ai systems are deeply socially
embedded good yeah so so that and that
actually is in contrast to the way
artificial intelligence have been talked
about throughout its history and
certainly now both on the robotic side
and the ai side
it's especially on the the tech sector
where
the businesses around ai they kind of
want to create um
systems that are like servants to humans
and then humans do all the beautiful
human messiness of
where art would be part
i i think that there is no reason why
you can't integrate ai systems
in the way you integrate new humans to
the picture they're just uh the full
diversity and the flaws all of that
adds to the thing yeah um like you know
some people might say
that alpha zero is this uh system from
deepmind that was able to achieve
uh
you know solve the game it beat the best
people in the world at the game of go
with no supervision from humans but more
interestingly to me on the side of
creativity it was able to surprise a lot
of grand masters
with the kind of moves they came up with
now to me
that's not the creativity the magic
that's socially embedded that we're
talking about that is merely um
revealing the limitations of humans to
discover
it's it's like uh
to solve a particular aspect of a math
problem
i think creativity is
not just um
not just even socially embedded it's the
way you're saying is it's part of the
communicative act it's the interactive
it's the dance with the culture and so
it has to be like for alpha zero
to be creative truly creative it would
have to be integrated in a way where it
has a twitter account
and it becomes aware
of the impact it has on the other grand
masters with the moves that's coming up
and these are one of the fascinating
things about alpha zero
which i just love so much
is uh i don't know if you're familiar
with chess i am yeah okay so the
it does certain things that most chess
players even at the highest level
uh don't do which is it sacrifices
pieces it gives pieces away
and then waits like
10 moves before it pays you back so it
does to me that's beautiful that that's
crazy that's art if only alpha zero
understood the artistry of that which is
uh
i'm going to mess with you
psychologically because i'm going to do
two things
one make you
feel overconfident that you're doing
well but actually also once you realize
you are playing alpha zero that is much
better than you you're going to feel
really nervous about what's on the like
is this is the calm before the storm and
that's
that creates a beautiful psychological
masterpiece of this chess game if only
alpha zero was
then
messing with you additionally to that
like and be was cognizant of it's doing
that then it becomes art and then it's
integrated into society in that way and
i believe it doesn't have to actually
have
an understanding
of
the world
in the way that humans have it can have
a different one it can be like a child
is as clueless about so many aspects of
the world and it's okay and that's part
of the magic of it just being flawed
being
lacking understanding all interesting
kinds of ways but interacting and so to
me it's it's possible to create art for
ai but
exactly as you're saying in a
deeply socially embedded way
good well i think i i think we agree but
let me just highlight the thing that
makes me think that we agree yeah which
is that
i think for people
for community
to allow themselves
to
recognize in
a certain kind of creative act let's i'm
thinking of stravinsky here but we could
think of a chess thing
to recognize in a certain kind of
creative act
a new and admirable worthy way of
thinking about what's significant in the
situation
you have to believe
that it wasn't random
you have to believe that stravinsky
wrote that way
because
he was receptive to what needed to be
said now
and so you you said if only
alpha zero
could do all this
by virtue of recognizing that this was
the thing that needed to be done
then it would be socially embedded in
the right way and i think i agree with
that first of all
it's possible to do in a constrained
domain a game playing domain go or chess
goes more complicated than chess but but
either one of them because there really
are only a finite range of possibilities
if you you know make the game end at a
certain point there's
there um
it's a combinatorial problem in the end
now obviously
alpha zero doesn't solve the problem in
a combinatorial way that would be sort
of take too much energy you couldn't do
it it's too too it sort of uh explodes
the problem
um so it does it in this other way
that's interesting this pattern
recognition way roughly
and and in that context it may well be
that it
that it can see
having had lots and lots of experience
on in the training stuff against itself
or against another version of itself it
can see that the sacrifice here is going
to pay dividends down the road
see i put that in in quotation marks
that's to say uh it's got you know a
high weight to this move here
as a result of experience in the past
where that move
down the line led to this this
improvement
so
so in that in that finite context i
think you know
the game players can trust it and they
talk that way that it's got a kind of
authority
um they say i've read some people who
said about
alpha zero when i played go
uh it's like it's playing from the
future
it's making these moves that are just
outlandish
and there's a kind of brilliance to them
that we can't really understand we'll be
catching up to it forever i think in
that context like it's mapped the domain
and the domain is mappable because it's
a combinatorial problem roughly
but in something like music or art of a
of a
non-finite form
it feels to me like
i i it's a little harder for me to
understand what the analog
of our trusting that stravinsky has
recognized something about us
that demands that he write this way that
doesn't seem like a finite
thing in quite the same way now now we
could ask we could ask the system why
did you do it we could ask
stravinsky why did you do it and maybe
it will have answers
but then it's involved in a kind of
communicative act
and i think lots of times artists will
often say look i i can't communicate
better than what i've done in the piece
of work and that that is the statement
yeah yeah so the yeah we humans aren't
able to answer the why either yeah but i
do think the the the question here is
uh well first of all language is finite
uh certainly when expressed to a tweet
uh so it is also a combinatorial problem
the question is how much more difficult
it is than chess
and
i i think
i think all the same ways that we see
the solutions to chess is deeply
surprising when it was first
addressed with ibm d blue and then with
alphago and alphago zero alpha zero
i think in that same way language
can be addressed and communication can
be addressed i don't see having done
this podcast
many reasons why everything i'm doing
especially as a digital being on the
internet
can't be done by an ai system eventually
so like i think we're being very
uh human-centric and thinking we're
special i think one of the hardest
things is the physical space
actually operating like touch and the
magic of body language and the music of
all of that because it's so deeply
integrated through the
long evolutionary process of what it's
like to be on earth
what is
fundamentally different and ai has
can catch up on is the way we apply our
evolutionary history
on
the way we act on the internet and the
way we act online and as more and more
of the world becomes digital you're now
operating in a space where ai
is is behind much less so
like we're both starting at zero
you